how's Cumbres my name is Pippa today I'm
gonna play a game called bullets to
Worman but before we begin we have to
take a step back this game was marketed
through a demo which is probably the
greatest demo of all time I never
actually played it myself but I'm
goddamn excited to do recalls the calm
before the storm
this is a parody it is not associated
with activation or a Call of Duty games
oh [ __ ] you baby what it's like every
color of Duty game summarize there and
what in one frame okay can I kill him
[Music]
break up Master Sergeant person [ __ ]
yeah so al get Rick [ __ ] they just hold
their nose well doing the voice I think
all right I'll shout you break up Master
Sergeant humor sergeant person [ __ ] yeah
oh god why does happen it's that a stick
I better get that sick you picked up a
small meaning a stick
Congrats thanks game
now preaching the drama of the story
hahaha you cannot stop me unless the
game goes into slow motion for some
reason and I become easy to shoot
all right slow motion time baby I'm
gonna give this man two pair of tits oh
jesus [ __ ] christ right girl for [ __ ]
sake it's still spot-on with all the
color the games inside Jesus Christ I am
a paratrooper because that is a
real-life war scenario why not shoot me
because this is a cutscene to make the
game feel more dramatic okay movie soon
I'll be landing I have landed on the
ground
[Music]
yeah I hold the nuclear missile bomb I
will never give nuclear missile bomb to
you now nuclear missile bomb to us me
boss and then put your hands up okay
USA is dominant
[Music]
[Laughter]
bullets are okay yeah I'm sold you got
me Bulletstorm also known as sticks joke
simulator my kind of game press Enter
windows [ __ ] like seriously I don't
want to play online [ __ ] off
I'm gonna play offline okay I'll I'll
use my I think I had one I'm not sure
what's the last time I [ __ ] use this
oh it worked
okay I got into my code [ __ ] sake
you're not showing me the entire code
[ __ ] sake oh great why it's my live ID
locked why should I have to oh great
thanks calm down
[Applause]
are you [ __ ] kidding me Thomas the
Train fan lover 1960 Oh God
don't be a [ __ ] lamps are my favorite
thing in the whole wide world
I once ate a turtle it tasted good
1969 1969 1969 dragon vagina tastes like
chicken
1969 oh my god I want to chop off my
hands and feed them to the poor if this
doesn't work I swear to God
the Windows Live ID you enter does not
exist
oh my god
I think we might actually get the plane
out
press Enter
just log me I know when I'm defeated you
win you [ __ ] win you win you did it
you did it you wasted everyone's time
thank you I'm gonna go and sacrifice my
blood to the Xbox gods and hopefully
next video we can actually play the game
you like for [ __ ] if I know
and I'll see you in the next one as
always stay awesome breaths it's coming
from my neighbor it's coming from a
neighbor it's coming from my label hence
its neighbor juice mmm I love me I love
you and I especially love neighbor juice